ome of the most difficult to repair damages
of the Donald Trump era are going to be the
alliances that have been ruined by Donald
Trump's presence in the oval office and indeed
the United Kingdom is now abandoning its Alliance
with Donald Trump over the Iran crisis.
And we've talked before about how the United
States is increasingly out of important climate
change discussions worldwide. Why would you
invite the country that backed out of the
Paris climate Accords and who's president
believes climate change is a hoax created
by the Chinese? You wouldn't. The United States
is increasingly out of those discussions.
The U S is increasingly acting alone and belligerently
in international agreements like the Iran
nuclear deal where Donald Trump decided we're
just simply going to bail. We're going to
leave everybody else in the deal out to dry.
Despite the reality that Iran did not violate
any element of that deal. The United States
is increasingly running a foul of our allies
with actions like Donald Trump's on Iran in
the unauthorized assassination of Kaseem Sola
Mani, which we've been covering and now we've
heard from the UK defense secretary Ben Wallace,
who says that Donald Trump's isolationist
and unilateral behavior is making the UK look
for alternative allies.
This is one of our most important alliances
and they're saying we're looking elsewhere.
Here's Ben Wallace speaking to the Sunday
times two days ago. I wonder if the United
States withdraws from its leadership around
the world. Over the last year, we've had the
U S pullout from Syria, the statement by Donald
Trump on Iraq where he said NATO should take
cover and do more in the middle East. The
assumptions of 2010 that we were always going
to be part of a U S coalition is really just
not where we are going to be. Regardless of
what the U S does, we are going to have to
make decisions that allow us to stand with
a range of allies. The five eyes. That's the
intelligence partnership with the U S Canada,
Australia and New Zealand and our European
allies where our interests converge. The United
Kingdom is publicly saying this isn't just
happening behind closed doors. They are publicly
saying, we're not sure, but our Alliance with
the United States, we are looking elsewhere.
They're also looking at reducing their dependence
on us military assets. A Wallace saying we're
very dependent on American air cover and American
intelligence surveillance and reconnaissance
assets. We need to diversify our assets, which
we could see as good. It's good that they
be independently, uh, sort of sustainable
when it comes to defense, but it is also a
big red flag when it comes to foreign policy.
And what we've seen is alliances over the
last many decades. And meanwhile Donald Trump
is also threatening to reduce intelligence
sharing with the U K. so if you are a total
like isolationist nationalist type, you want
to build walls instead of bridges and do everything
ourselves with nobody else. You may actually
like this. The problem is that it's absolutely
terrible for the United States economically
as well. Even if you like isolationism politically
and theoretically in practice in 2020 when
our economy is so interlinked with those of
our allies in so many ways, this is very bad.
And the scariest thing about it is that many
Trumpists aren't worried. They're not scared.
They're not concerned about this because Donald
Trump has successfully primed them to see
everything he does, his alpha behavior. If
allies are abandoning us, it's because Trump
has shown them, I dunno, that he's doing what's
best for the U S not for them. And they're
realizing now that Trump exists to make America
great again, not to make the U K great. So
good for Trump. Uh, allies abandoning us as
a sign that Donald Trump is doing really well.
And this is the type of post facto reasoning
that if Trump did it, it must have been good
for the United States. And that makes the
echo chamber very difficult to Pierce. So
this story is about the alliances that will
take a long time to repair once Donald Trump
has gone. But it's also a story about the
way in which a Trumpist is able to justify
any action that Donald Trump takes.
If it's a, or if it's the opposite of a, either
way, it's Trump doing the right thing. If
Trump did something that impressed the UK
and made them say, wow, Trump did something
good, you have Trump is saying, look at what
a great job Donald Trump is doing. Or just
like he said, uh, he's making the U S respected
or whatever, which Donald Trump said we weren't
under Barack Obama, but we would be again
under Donald Trump. If our allies abandon
us the same Trumpist will insist Trump's doing
what he promised. It's America first. Here
is make America great again. Screw our allies.
Donald Trump is here to do what's best for
the United States. And then on the tail end
of this, you have the geopolitical considerations
who will come in, who will take leadership
responsibility. We've seen it sort of to a
degree be German chancellor, Angela Merkel.
Uh, but this is a perfect example of why Vladimir
Putin loves the instability caused by Donald
Trump, a West that is increasingly leaderless
looking for a leader, realigning those alliances.
That's an opportunity for Russia, period.
And this is, you don't even have to get into
Putin, help Trump beat Hillary. It's not an
analysis of interference or any of that. It's
simply an analysis of the real world. Vladimir
Putin benefits and sees opportunity as a result
of weakened leadership in North America and
Western Europe. And Donald Trump is perpetuating
that in this vicious cycle that is endlessly
defended by his followers in a style reminiscent
of a combination of George Orwell's 1984 but
of course also brave new world
by Aldous Huxley